the Joe Rogan experience and and that's
why I could turn prison into a religious
retreat because it's like a monk going
you know into hiatus for for nine months
you just had a thought in your head that
you're gonna treat it like a religious
retreat yeah and you learn about
yourself and educate yourself read all
the books take advantage of your
solitude because that's very important
when you get a chance to be alone man
that's a very important time because
that's when you connect with the the
spiritual ears spiritual teacher how
must it must have felt so good to be
released though in a way there was a lot
of sadness really yeah yeah I never
looked as good as when I got released
man but one of the because one of the
inmates there it was a barber he spent
two hours cutting my hair perfect
Chicano you know it just perfect I came
out with my wife you shall be looked at
me whoa that's the best haircut you've
ever had it was perfect we exercise it
in jail that's all you do you walk at
night there's a track and you can walk
miles I'm on the chart in the whole
prisons out there walking around walking
around that's when you're socialized you
talk and everything else to people in
that and they all group together and I
learned games I learned how to play
bocce ball learn I played pool and
they're saying I had a little area where
I had my own private studio it was a
entrance to the pool hall and I'd sit in
there the echo was perfect you guys had
a pool hall oh yeah we had tennis courts
pool halls a great time it was other
than not being able to leave and even
then if you wanted to leave why would
you want to leave I mean it was
perfectly seating that's why people go
back to jail I get released early I saw
one guy who it was sad he was crying but
he's sitting there crying anyway I said
what's wrong he's he gets released next
month and he was a junkie and he knew
that soon
hit the street he was going to die he
was going to die you know and he did he
as soon as he hit the street he died but
he lost he was funny he was but they had
a little game that when they opened the
dormitory the first few people to hit
the mess hall got to order eggs anyway
they wanted like over easy or sunny
side-up whatever and so he he'd get all
anxious he'd be the first guy in line
and he'd be kind of getting ready to sue
the doors open man he did and you
couldn't run you had to walk and so he
learned that this walk fast it worked
real fast and and he was he was a
delight but when he got released he took
his own life Sam yeah
I hung his own life with heroin or
probably yeah that's probably it was it
was sad just couldn't help himself once
you know well see you know everybody's
worried about socialism well America is
a bigger socialist country in the world
we are yeah we've got more people in
jail than anywhere else in the world and
what's it what is it what happens in
jail cradle to grave you're fed you're
clothed you're told what the where
you're told what the way what the -
you're allowed to study certain things
you're totally controlled medical you
got free medical there are prisoners
that would go to jail so they get their
open-heart surgery because the federal
law and mandate said if you have
something wrong with you they have to
fix it and so there were prisoners that
would break the law so they can get in
to get their open-heart surgery Wow
yeah that's crazy man that's some
next-level thinking I'm gonna go to jail
so I can get open-heart surgery yeah
yeah what did what did they prevent you
from reading any books was there
anything that was like could you order
whatever you wanted they they had a it
was weird they had a thing about they
would take covers off magazines and and
you know the my subscription cards they
would take that out because people on
the outside would Dolson with the acid
and ship the books in there and then
next thing you know half a dorm would be
tripping on acid they're eating pieces
of paper and that that kind of stuff
always went on but as far as now you
could read whatever you wanted basically
you know I read a lot of books that you
know I was many to read you know and I
helped a lot of people I would do the
etching you know the each in Shore yeah
I would do the itching you know how to
do that under Indian grounds oh yeah
yeah it's real easy yeah throw the coins
this really had you know well though
it's supposedly it's some sort of like
future reading yeah thing do you think
it works
oh yeah what does it tie yeah well first
time I did it yeah I rolled it i did my
explain to people how it works
well what it is you get three coins and
and you you throw the three coins and
you get numbers from six to nine and
anything in between six seven six eight
nine
I think this something like that anyway
each number tells you what line you're
going to read and you saw it three times
and you're right down and then you get a
sort of like a plan of what page you're
supposed to look at and then when you
get the page then it tells you you know
but but you're asking it because you got
to ask the eaching for what perhaps
something you know and it'll answer it
it'll answer you it's for instance I
threw mine when I did it I threw it and
the first line said you are in jail for
a reason whoa how does it say that it
just said it well it says it how is it
what do you translate it you read it
it's been written in that book for
centuries that line has was in the in
that book for centuries really 3,000
years something like that and so I read
it because still they still talk about
chariots and Kings and lanes they're in
there
and that was the first science you are
in jail for a reason gels are corrective
institutions that will correct your
behavior that's what the eat chain is
telling you that's what the eating well
what they did they updated the girls
that wrote it they updated it to the
modern time mm-hmm
you know it's I think it's Armstrong is
the girls that there are a couple of
girls wrote it's a big thick book but it
hits hid and then went on there and
another guy Mike this this Chicano he
saw me so he thought it was a game so
he's all set for the game what would you
play in I said no I'm doing the eating I
said you want me to do you and he said
yeah so I did his and it's very polite
not to read the readings of the other
guy you know let him read it first
and so I I did the numbers and and I
give it to him and he read it and he
just handed me the book and you went sat
on his bunk and he just stared and so
then I read what was what it said and he
a month before he lost his wife in child
in a car accident they were coming out
to visit him and the eaching said you
suffered a great misfortune oh it was
like dead-on Wow and the itching goes on
to tell you you know what to do and you
know this is next month's it's gonna be
tough this months is gonna be good you
know and we see hope for you it's like
astrology it's almost the same but I
know my Terence Mckenna was really into
it he's really into the eating and he
thought it was some sort of a map of
time he was trying to figure out what it
was and how it worked and why I can
predict things and if you mess with it
it'll it'll tell you [ __ ] with it like
it's easy board you know sometimes if
you do the Ouija board it's same thing
and if you start making it a game you
know let's ask it this I had to get that
who's gonna win the race tomorrow on
that
and right away the itching catches that
and knows your real feelings and it
tells you you know tell you don't don't
do what do you think it is it's a
Chinese it's a mess I think she I think
what it is it's a spiritual way of
communicating us remembering ghosts were
Patrick Swayze had to learn how to move
a coin mm-hmm remember that yeah
the spirits especially spiritual people
and they're around us and so you give
them a chance to communicate with you
because they know all they will
communicate and so the e Ching gives the
spirits a chance to communicate so when
you throw a coin they know what what
what heads or tails or whatever it is
numbers that you need read to talk to
you right and that's that's my theory
hmm gotta try it me yeah I'm curious
because I do know that many people have
used it to try to figure out what their
life is about what they're doing with
their life and the weirdest thing about
it is they they seem to find some real
answers in it and they keep them to them
talk yeah but that the idea that I had
heard that made the most sense was that
the way the world works is not as simple
and as easy as one plus one equals two
left right left right walk down the road
but that there's intention and thought
that also helps formulate our universe
and what the eaching does is it somehow
clarifies intention and thought and it
clarifies like the the actually your
actual the actual process is going on in
your mind and it quantifies it and puts
it into like a way that you can read
your affect on life and life's affect on
you in this and then it reads it somehow
or another even though it doesn't make
any sense well it made sense to the
nation's yeah of discovering yeah what's
happening yeah it's a method of
communicating with the spirit world you
think that's what it is oh yeah
and in the thing is getting back to the
AI the artificial intelligence that we
already use artificial intelligence in
our lives everyday like Alexa she's a
good exam a [ __ ] yeah I love her she's
very never steered me wrong yet
you know she's told me I've asked the
wrong questions right but I see this is
my theory is that that we are we
everybody who in the universe wants us
and the spirits they want us to be
enlightened
you know because more enlightened we are
the more we can enjoy but we what we've
inherited because when you're born into
this world you you've inherited you're
taking it for granted Kingdom amazing
yeah you've inherited it especially in
comparison to the rest of time all the
human history this is the greatest time
the greatest most unfortunate see look
at look at look oh we got now going for
us now and how much effort did that take
you know it was like being part of a
team and so when you're ready a boom
you're pushed out in front you're up
there man and so you know our our duty
as as students is to learn everything we
can learn and to teach whatever we can
teach you know and that's why there
should be no paranoia because we're not
here long enough so that being rich or
being poor him makes any kind of a
difference you know because you know
yourself I mean what do you really need
in this life right you know what do you
really need water food companionship
love yeah France yeah yeah and something
interesting that you like to do
[Applause]